the falkland do you silent premium place of
destination air
and also fill them
backlog silent my name is super
our often duivesteijn
work as she interviews media is built with
deep impact in switzerland and because it
also
short message classification and ice
power to this pickle pee it  voor
instance the user
slack too too c with which we bizar en en
zo
hmmm zo weer at a company with great
liberty work and how do things but would
be a way of the champion recruit meeting
or would be to home of is voor in should
be announced  its lack and so de everybody
knows where were you done
it won point we thinking how many
kind of
get some statistics old fit and see
what the f zippers en were people use it
for
and so before we don't
admit it's mattered to her  do i
already have factories and see if i can
do it nicely automatically this
everybody heft is
posted orie en en contrairement in case
you want to do to follow i do it so
it seems so expose some of the
librari  es and this book will use life
that
safeword and and wonderful to live to
delight now features that he major
long ago money from
so it just the name and so the
details 11
that him young chol it's not such nice
details want to date and that  least
chance with role that
or on the difficulties whiteness
so the sun times difficult to
chocolate in in classes
it a multi klaas problem would put it
to the binary it's not fair
fast
or like sentiment analysis its positive
or negative
this zoë still place  is your locker gone
is full on its track and girls flower
the details at it agree furby smolov
if
necessary from max would test my
country and that the mix x if we work hard for and
maybe help save be
reliable and
the number of  samples per klaas
articles from you that sand dune chef
just a few messages
put in front of all classes cities dare
of messages so
the upgrade knows him en to the buyer's
towards van class en
let's see if i  can solve the is can the
pictures so
way blood goes this is with school with
not
zoom in
so
with let's have looked at it what side or
here what else can you do
or with shirts who do I lift the first one
from the pick up a car van  de gaucho
hang after lief het gif before the
five on thursday so this could be that
somebody guests who chose from little bit
earlier
once on body already idea of ​​this
is our own meer op de previati for home
office and how they go
a mismatch a so here will be little
bit late her edge of is and so
when i together discount of messages
from on white
anti splash is so nice
you're too late where you during office
hours michael recently for you from
debteur de foil case for  gadget
grew is
home or one day you would be a nice pattern with an
owner-occupied home
you claim yourself whole with wood consultation
I call me nice pray to a number
tribe I become pilatus options in or so
that you say a country or is it a
lot sometimes
and  miscel  laneous so that can be anything
health
so help these classes in in the
dictionary
and that die furby
draw th models intro put together a machine
and remain a find some way to
put the text
intro santing that the computer can
computer of so it became him district
number  out of text and one of the
message that you can use this by using
effects space modder and what your purpose is
of the wave put of documents it
will be your coal corpus fg board it you
find you will give it an index number
and this index number  3 percent than the
position of the cheek and in a very long
vector so has the corpus led cs5 samson
boards and every word he is an
effector of for thousand nine hundred
knight china in serious and won warm it
the place of its
index so in display  wi-fi percent f
keyboard and effector and for ted you can
do
a girl fingers it gets tough now
the document
some lines from alice in wonderland there
has well this is put or for
documents
week and good all these wor  ds into vector
en and the doc siemens in
effector chair so first
what your goal is of the board
who you fit and index
and co lead [ __ ] tomorrow he would be
belt or alrighty so toparts ajax is in pain
there is what it is not
and you see that  of this corpus
own sphere of words wit and an index
and if i look at
ben the document and je nfi
document so all the words who the vector
who and
and the sprig of coin this self is effector
where evry word he in count it
into a new  effector show for in
its series be come to pass it will be
there psv times and that your problem will not come
until six
so that's my and if you look at
it is line this document in that the
village with paper freetime would you chew
it become it
and so  e50 document and then want to fit
him in this a vector space modal
other words that are not called recent
get in this sector space modeled and
will be side the essay we massive in
this case sony
alice and cat eye recently called it in that
vector space  middle of the other wo  rds
will be so that's my years i do stick
people that percent it is largely very
house and oil the boards the porn earth
because so so effects space model sfx
size the pensions jules recipes
what you can lived xpander suffered
what a master time after time  had
leaked out to make and internet well I heal
a switch those aspects space modder you
can dory in brass things you can find
you make search engine
so something rich and time again fierce set of
four documents and I all that so and
that's comedy  splits
and those two are here
the and matrixx wells for document
well let's make a priori
a split very well known
so lets make aquarium poule a youngster
issue is alice maid but so
this period i percent it an effector
with us to be in the vector space  motherwear
account
the becomes ls a girl and well out how it
to product so that he shakes the lord
device young and then to product and what
it for the party and brave he is well
sam so are you sam interaction  lingehaven
score for you though your search has been
played out and stuff
and if it's documents score na or
free and what ice respond
is the answer for my question is alice
met and help your customer evict cat
why bedchair and medjool met so you can use
our and  nice make another curry
must will do
so see it and here it is that
and not and get to new document city
that where kind of it with energy market
it the first find and doing that there's
one time alice ss second of
corstius family shops or word that
peer in every document double u payroll
the time of the top seems the stop result
who and who and petting and stuff
to make it a little bit better enjoy
peter scoring every white and
manhoef the scoring is every winter is the
french former
like i am i  am or pm
twenty five then beautiful score every
furious and this will show you for a
class fly so that makes the words that
an important and are not come in and
free document table appear on top
the goals against  dr often you go value in
the ones that a very common double offers
analyzed and the caddle ever so daymond
shell so much and that are ports for
your class fire to so fine for instance
the
tfs trends for trickle see that station
sides so harmony times your  is there
per signal in the document and the in
first document frequency at the very least did
n't pass me by a patch dashboard in
roll roof you have to so
and so
now you see that instead of having
interiors with account
ipad well whistled
that beetle wait to every word and  how
important bucket and do you have very
large corpus
the least that they the and the word
package that per app free document
lot of times with I have
ver milan score and this is us you
just can't get this such a safe word I
like the  man stands after hours ranking and
dead is stopped for so long is
already enjoying works well done and the
corpus is large enough and your
and month of documents is often you understand
who you would rather not
have to stop belt it
so  sticks became earth is the paper
in in many document and has viewer
did is it is mol it's recommended most
of the time to remove the so the class
of hired as not get could views
at that payroll time the argan
and so this is  the stop it reads for
what is divided into a nl chica and that
side factua your brain safeword learn
stress well
and that wang is an air mattress larger you would
you have to find out which of a
works best for your case to see which
good
if you  want to get rit of them which
reads you want to use we just do
we that all
vote where you truncated awards
so for instance if your computer
computers computer computer die is there
variations of the or so one word device
can this now then  you see that all these
words
i have the scene
shape and that will help your classifier
has jf especialy of your own face
better put
cabinet and it can wake up sitting more
and cap
can give more or less know do it so
mechanically very cattle  l bit of the the
building blocks that week and us to to
start a class fire that locks detail in
this speeddate that that that he showed
you but now it's an ot that wit
klaassen shed and this is with them so
right sit down and then  go to do list
and be on the rates on sunday bit
of teachers had so when we do this
hey yo shaved the ex your input that's
the text column it's mama and the why is
young claus so this is team i
output it
it was split ring and now
the start with your mother or argument
reason does the very simple basics a first
so in this case it is the count
factorize
and then class fire and for this one that
shows the linear
sport vector music and this choice is
pico's for in this case which is very
heart beat the linear
support fact machine so
and when train you see that under
scratch games dation on iphone ready a
meme
score of anyone patient and under task or
i that two percent something that
classifier he is then quite  good  job i
if it melts about fit it is the the
score of the training in the test set arm
morales so its end
yoshi young the stop that the ethics is your
patient for you that quite good and we
have then different and emmy went
under the step  who allows this here
potential improfit who knows not use this
so
the Ijsselcollege very good idea to
start with the ferry basics and then a
test to because I as the very basic chef
then in
very short amount of time will report it to
notation media in  list to the d and then
you can spend a lifetime in proofing
it for more so what
lets look at what has been done there so
you can do these steps already with them and
putin in a yoko saito classes are
great way to
compactness and  the put it all together
and that blame a pipeline
so your fico
it is helper function want i meet you
see that only here the pipeline and the
steps and the staff is a list of junk
as with you i give it a century and the
object  that you want to to putin this
and
he sees d  at he often had long went so
with proofreader the trainees als
en plat die computer matrixx and education
eksept for die in or is one that
des frais die is full gargamel there zo
the class of fire to be quite good job
oren of death on  this simple means en
zo if you want to look into the pipeline
the pipeline is matte black box is you can
open this and look insight
mystique at parameters and hear you can
see the things that i have put into
closed steps first die the steps of de
lister is the application that you chicken and
times so
you see the vector they were in the class of
fire
die sar hart of dixie you will get
you well for instance for the vector
eyes there when i do it is object of the
pipeline what  just queen and they are there
dictionary
and transform a new new
document and bitset well white actor
rebuilt
show frequency and in fresh document
frequently to make to comb murder less
important and the worse so that the special
workflow reporter and stuff  lets see how we
can improve our class of your way hit by
just putting it in site a pipeline zoey
fast facts riser twitter can factorize
tembea transvorm it with die
tfa dr transforme and thereby push the
classification with an illusion and as you
can see in the  tin test his little bit
would become well cross validation or I choose
phoebus and ten and the test or
eli for percent
what it's not use this if i do the
mood so
video the mood would eat the toot ankh
becomes see what effect or that  is
i can run them topic and and now we can
easily need
safeword as old as this taste it's
martin test and that's funny and one of
the reasons can be
time the pilot there sticks words that
buy actress toppers you shoot it
things like a  noee
myself who parents old wood
these words go w and white shirt messages
maybe design port and see if you said
idaho or is lucas
here is in the jo heften stay home
mikoshi rocket is whole
or it mini suntip.nl mail so removing
s  toppers halftone think if it's really
help huge
colic and pike
en and on a white to to to
vector a short to say if you to make
your mobile battery or more complicated
is to not look out
single heartbeat again this gentleman want to
look at two  words so cross together
and that mix there are speckles
if you look at two words together home
and or is that just wet snow ice
or is ss scared
so you can do is here c and gramm
is 2 out of junk can must this  that's well
it is that organizing one world
at detail it organizers of two words
it it at times oh that's my hi don't
is warm
don't want this money and now
you know the voices may be in
office home office and or  is so
and no way to this tool has the backup
words that is that that
june came from the cheek jerked nigher
and the by klein model together so denyo
range is just about two and in vidoe
that you can and let you must  on where
does the single have tokens and that
each time with type you can just d  oen en
won number of trade and then you can
disable every time the tokens became
word and the tokens with who is so that
is callback to our list of possibilities
so elicits well the moods and stoppers
and he just use the en grams again
deer camp er work with  this one
as far as that score around the website is adrian
100sft that for a philo kati
and grams but who use one and two
etui and eighty-five
so can help it x mate or your
nephew target
porn tv in this case the school and the
tests  is e die sex under depth and
still i free if you look at range and the
choice of
zu nine to eat section here you eat the
episode by once
tends to be tent pole a little bit
smaller so now also learn how a very
honor and diffuser  tol gather
also that it is nice to that at all when
the times onward
lot of times in in the details it
and every time now get
a new something to your word that the
machine head to learn
so
what axes time after time so
between my ear
after ginger nine ze  ro zero online or five
for az zwolle time for the machines
everytime and your yard
and what you can do to mars chris is
here he does such a
tough expression heavy a mask
time them at try to find the times in the
in the details it  a target of
cleaning where he is arguing
this kind of captain and those emotions
i smilies and je links eye cream
smal en fr those emotions en tag toe zo
and those in teachers so
advise the numbers i was he stay free
on this out
5 hours  hear such a number know that helps us to be
next to the good the classifier
information will either gypsies
and you are stuck with
mood and stop words and that man
came apart will pointee too often so
just look at all the possibility is that
you the us now  to tool in taste your model
you see it there is somewhat that your
direction in chili
that you guys cannot get much higher and
one of the reasons
da's ni body
now what could be one of two reasons
sorry detail six wheels yes dat stats for
nerds man wat  there are these  standards and the
outsite
what what is one in the classroom offline
willy willy counters detail the so many
messages hand gun allowed to place such a box
summer in the messages that contain no
type so what or corstiaan the
teapot ex-husband so
or usa and  do i deliver as a forklift from the
doctor or
did he think that the doctor den
and what does such a home office and avb in
office pancho insert the new v-class
totality i have such a person the machine
can not show any and twin it will  it seems
like i live and he has the
machine and who train them maybe
pics
led they message to incite is this
document that picks up the and the food house
message follicles that area city
the most important message and insights
girls and you sure to miss  classroom
crash
hey we never old days with any of the
algorithm for with any of the die die
vote
thanks that you can do so has to find
some things like bij de district
times already such and
example for quick charge i like a
violin de  the will
t  hings by hand it can be quite ideas and
such a drink or some what the magnifying glass
for
such monument to to to this it is a
search
with all the parameters automatic li is
when I ate white shirt
million designer or poor it is that you
want to look at for the widget also an
ice cream because
or just a mood ornata
white matter was slightly injured reviews
[Music]
die and gremlins you can you can the fine
preprocessor that you like the problem
and then such a big girl eyes and  parameters
you can check then you note you might
go to their start this well i was the
license plate iphone and the now the quick search
could give you the best parameters that
this was possible in this detail in die
and notebooks is also a great choice for
any  first class' fire
so our parameters had to be order
eksept for the class or life coach what you
lucy dat if you're on this that
die linear svm offers three hearts so
well that's forming
[Music]
you can see that at the  pulls is my prince
a penny
hello human  and from me it knew
that's it
again i live fashion and
in and putin new a document and this
is what that class fire came so put and
and think it's pretty good m in but
alarm clock
was wet they pulled player campiglio or
is  and sunnah just
happened something fiberglass suffered in early is my scatter
against or asylum inch usb is sometimes count of
oil there is a not feeling well and
stiffness of the kind where bag
events language is super simple ryokan
microarray the sun shines had or it
is
what nice move the plans is that sam
girls jesse lee he has to poll graders
and
color show you some ways to
between the head is
so
it is what it is
know you les line brise can the help of
functions
is the food running well just anyone  silent the
snow
details it know the white single
klaas zo the
the annotation no snoopy change the
details mapping change and down to
predict nou met fj message wit
nuts graders such a man to join
it is not to predict the extr  a
klaas is the probability of africa's
left to change the linear spmt s see that
that will be our sport vector maybe
klaas of fire
some white linen jarno like
lower the implementation she prays infant
and the prediction scram be lived in
france frogs of alive in met  me against
with client
so bottom are so primitive a this
and me and this is the simplest possible
and it's just econtrack when he are
to trix dan so we can trust and
that
so perfect maybe classification
would be more of score
etiquettes pour les wat de
loosdorp  it you can see iphone soon so f
well because document from johan or is
and leds in star or his protect you give
the tag preach
problem want it i put it in and what your
china is smell that try it here or
afri klaas and you can  that professional
chad himself would do
besides the choice lucky fresh gold is-pro
factory place you're looking
are in this case in the ham or is
there a cape schmidt the high sparrow
buttocks  tea
and before antiquity
that if the products place so die
let's have document here that is a bit
more tricky so
and kool bigirly you dat
klaasvan de en
en fluke point at the doctor so claes to
and then will do trade fish live free
messages fast in  man document and that
she loves you just shave
and would this is you that I try the output
sector with that
bilities nephew flat this what
nice well cbd hot shot and say point
to you miss van klaas
so what he is it right here is to
computer the dynamic
that fresh old is self perfection of shot
where your time the maximum of your
probability
than the fire by for the least that you
can more or less
product free blazers i already
had those west is for form and in
this
are you vulnerable is simple trick a
multi label
multi klaas predictor and you didn't do
anything with
the theta re annotations
and that the trick is a use just versast
west class fire
zo nou instead of training jobs class
of you t  rain for every klaas a new
class of fire so eat classifiers and
jef toe notk detail and a doubt
ot and free message with de klaassen piece
you see
so here is a new calm that
blame note ii klaas where insight this
list of classers that  you will see in
this message and
what the machine is not capable of or
list of or graders with
in tits it doesn't get perfect the
sauce and mans
so it and solden soundshare
would very end up with the number of
messages and the number of graders
in  in a big fat and this fact roids
to the desperation factor is the factor where
you know multi launch in sideshow
vector
tammy duane a test and sexual
i climbed like the house to do
so well the class class fire
and well you see he track  luxury wheel
oh what is it whose outside the woman
lust is of course it what happens is
that i eat chicken shave
fries graders and the machine find on the
two or maybe for the golf
classification espina market if there is anything
it was and the heft or something
like that who
have a look at some of the prediction
mire
just get the conformation for me point
point in the morning
om men app will be or in the morning
and johan or or is after lunch
so it soup production  no more is
home office and miscellaneous so this
blah blah
the machine a nice anne or is this
nadori at the
production here try where you from the 20
years to the 30 december
the product that texting tour the suffering
gets early wet and  or knew in fact it's
all idea of ​​this is oil and miss
classification
here so
that she
oh yes this is a lingerie man
my fashion top between point idea behind
new sowerby in the office
deliver lunch so it's predict it
he's
home office and  medical point
maybe tips to here a brand compoint
with about the annotating oil
already with the cooking pan with such
in this case the eating we just
a machine was right
would disk and have it on and the effect or
coach score
so i  k and my wie through such a test and
look at what it predicts
best maybe that out
then a lot fight with then come to the
or is the greek won label an honor it
is musket shot and you or is very
enthusiastic  a matter school idea
and in the hof is pikachu comeback conchos
trek so they went to bed is
it's really not bad so my message here
is that the score numbers to not tell you
and eats everything in your life to look
at horizon and i drove  would less detail
and some of the myth classifications
between v2
that bed and mast parties it's not
yes and this is
solus in line can on it just as long
ago
xlii want the promiss for the mass class
fashions time is your 5
messages year  long and kent comes a wet
pee
one way to solve this problem is to
cut it in shepherd
smal comics and the yes
doing is
so channel is fi  rst the sentences and
their classified ad free sentence
and that he who de the library this
and recently a bunch of channel in this is this
very careful the center documentations
so be there prosthesis the open
house is to bionda
for creatures and such a philo this and  that
see how you add bf4 centers of
alice in wonderland i in and
rfs sentence that is clearly marked with
with the comma and oh sorry
and efficient and city equally sweet the guts
and em
fine charges meeting
that alice and will be back after 14
others would  that so efficient and sets
what the tank and iser of sciatica
will give any one and so many
leds moment at the first it's
just that stoke my first
the simple sentence
in the this die notk that's your job a
lot of tv to the other  one and wit
that's note is so becomes 4 cents intersteel
residential center so has the comb on the
zatinge as and we that apropos
to do it once
post tagging so part of speech watch the
show test sentence you can lift
content driver because lie  f ago
help or that sentence
so effie tel channel is rather one
to it's just anyway every time like
the comma the turn end i was that close
to numbers together
the derrick village butt or a round asses
there you will split
danny target part of speech  look and look
for the toe horse would you look at two
parts together
your look for the two parts the boat sails
container fire and ablaze partners
sharps container verp
tennet closer together a can just not
split
is the to party target side a
firm that could mean  that the side two
sentences and you split het smit-kroes
what at least a little further levy lottery
and out think of you want to the roots en
tent and thomas you can catch on something that is
law so this is so
center splitting is is like is  the
frame bubble bath
labels see that it works quite well
so sharp from the the part of speech
cover that f and so on
charge for can and will be zo die
works
so in 5
split is now with the by post with a
first ajacieden notk
st  el capture one sentence and it's
new for post with the kidney
3 center rest and now we can take it
furry is that iphone meeting
apps elephant eleven so that class of
missing has
it brushes and and ruby ​​backup touch
class or two like that  de did aan
nam je do de the center splitting then
you call back to a notation
en eryie see that indeed this sentence
aspi split nou in into their eyes for
one message
6 pins buttons wie en en zoon en mijn
your dan met aan het essence you
exposed and
would you do something
that
s chicken I white shirt for
times tnt the residential city with the
best parameters and you very closely in
that time to score lasagna or a diet and
this is the best score sofar so
philip had he score  it so do you want to
go to bed and nephew location computer
with you twitch
the tough knol is dark with you scrubt
and that of that in or fashion outlet
in the distance model fits master all
wrong class fight
is about had to class wrong and
it's that percentages
and  she is a i often go up to run
oneself
some types
back mrs
am sorry yes yes
thank you very much zo
toe
ego is the wheel
so would you see after the function in
details that find here the product
function is it as the sunset organizer
inside  the project that all those stairs next to
the center sjors and it
joins all the toxic and so serious your
note ii time wasting
the last one that he because the show you
see that there are
many different ways to
optimal show classes and classes fire
but  some of the klaas is still free for
one optimize sunglasses prefer the
other optima is there and the cow 2nd
toe blend is and to have very robust
means that children girls if she is for
future productions to train and then
sandel and ere he ate  an ensemble
of the front classifiers with different
settings and so
we start train so until I impress him
that me
and d&ad is well that all that splice wants to
frame
outperform every individual place
so that that ghoul is now that
rive  r score of hr test set that will be
higher than any of these individual
classifiers zo let's give you can make
that
so your food stays white
well so it is so close classifiers er
class find all classes and son of de
klazes
d for in zo'  n steak thanks like the tree
of life
sam klazes then it turns out the by grams
gang basis day they prefer to heaven
sent recently tent and toto has the best
of all
is to be plants
must and so well you cee'd sw f
one two three four  five six classes
fires
and the max brooks course page 7 i have to put
it in a pipeline
or a list of pipelines blastoff models
and now start to protect and free
document for all classifiers
side that or out poll that probabilistic
and then tectum mix
so
and  if chelsea de well effe effe want
score whether
or not food so it is know going to help us
how do we know now small details to
hit
peter class sailing then that you can
have to single class of your balance
to best parameters
if we comp  uter matrixx is wheelie
there came that diagonal
so complex with on earth issues
[Applause]
[Music]
exki
are
those not yes o
from this notorious applause what is
he found out is that tips to
bodysafe he does a lot always hangs  je singel
other pages
after that like all get well soon
of something like that
and mustard aan mijn customers fire or if
you give you work with profile it is
probably not what if you were put
paragraphs wmf hank het hairdo we are
ready so is better to  wear light led it
is called that you can well of
things that you don't klaassen sail in
in in the mail klaas and your can make it
more robust of this was putting it
sentences and that to not work you in
your details that in  this case from this
to pickles that deception is place
was already salary time and that in
office klaas is the
narrow stream that there is already a
mismatch in that month or dating or just
not enough
in deceiving you search it with you
but what was d  at met levy models and
to come back to your question from think
it's cool to have a klaas that this
if you have nothing to put fire to
put it in their later class so he
knew he started pray for them does
messages that was not  enough
den oath unread messages this gives more
young people the results that he off
morales well no because up to a sleek 17 the
handshake misses
with the veneziano tent 17a nuts this not
make some us about those fans and humor and
that speakers who
die the time  of messages are quite
restrict the museum so that he that month
of words that huston in the hol corpus
the
2000 for what thumping something more so
fit was nice generic text and you do
n't need much more
yes
your account factor we so much and it
's a  your word a problem fill spicy
then someone if
f yes from document set lives heart
performance what is this document
probably be missed glass fight and that
you noticed his game there were free time
then the faceting not that
yes yes
yes may be good people
eijsink it
yes you can do it santing laugh earth from
a tank it is a profile proformance
with big sleep with most people do make
some a tractor from this nations to at
that time there was first
yes that is specially of your goal
multi klaas single label dan die de
murders length your text is die of
messages de de murder chansung f miss
class party
so we took you a night and sentences
would poke you up in the house in the morning
and get the sperm whale to come
so this  waving rosso di
the classf occasion score chose learned
with sharks but you do
yes
xlii hef us keep notebook this time
was implementation
but cry out is oh [ __ ] en en 11 cm
what the score fvf
if you try we again pull yourself the die
worship hotel for  ever green trains
muddle you can put your band tv
bunch so this kind of sisters first of
all the day is better narrow for
for a neural network so what he and
that point is your head to do early
stopping i  if you try for ever you
will be for your under of your website you
build and ninety-nine point ein ein
en om the test out two bija random
cash it is reality
so has the door lies topping to have
those mola's in balance board  and i you
we and that with a neural network that is
not fully trained and what you see is
the effect of your and him in micha
wiser and to overcome that you can
train
and an ensemble and build a machine
tripod that these are chicken  performance of
a maximum of
itv percent and there form score 3 and so
that's when you to your training of your
embedding itself of use
prix trains en weddings and then just
out the becomes in which your corpus in
a slice box perfector sin
johan bedding piece of monti  use google
very that the scores much less of macho
i have as the words that have been used
in this training
put like and previati equal a cell for
ham or is there trade fez bang word
it was with a pear in your portfolio
train and wedding  s so
that salmon is in terms of site and that she prays or
flat one would for this did there za because
document to use and weddings I as an
update ascetic betters mole
that from this not try out
maybe you can but some of the so that
of that  your station lift
for a network suggest a sheet
for it ds4 is
good question this shield work for
other languages ​​but tough guys
from this magazine from any language knowledge
into the mobile exactly for the safe word
joost and a lesson reads what to put
words
in  this case do the make such a also
so has reint chairman details it
for a company month but it was for your
network at which should work rosso for
fraud languages ​​from a checkpoint
truth endpaper
yes
well actually work the left out tough
be because how even  nice generic mud
and never because we have
buyer to someone' that is also bad
yes
a few
where f5
a stent well where you audition and those in
provence in perfumes perfumes
so that yes yes yes
j
yes that can  be if i don't know your date
at orde size of the details has he
specially my the details it is
narrow least the most of the bike grams of
the tribe grams
a unique and has that is the mind and the
class fire
justy  is it because and and gonna do
anything with it in view details it
is
is very large looks like your two wikipedia
the bad chickens
large improvement what has those details
it is search small
corpse here the nevertheless well in taste
my barrel I dab it nicely  dust de by
crèmes
especialy times they own unique
in you can pull way
yes
sunday have
be
yes yes kenny
yes if you have the morning time to know us is
correct
[Music]
[Applause]